President Biden and his administration
promising a response to is coming to the
deadliest attack on US troops in years
we had a tough day last night in the
Middle East you lost three brave souls
attack one of our BAS and we shall
respond president and I will not
tolerate attack on US
forces and we will take all necessary
actions to defend the us and our troops
respond decisively to any
aggression and we will hold responsible
the people who attacked our troops will
do so at a time in a place of our
choosing but so far it's all talk no
action right now the administration is
grappling with its failure to deter Iran
backed Terror groups who had launched a
deadly drone strike that killed three
American soldiers and injured at least
40 others the Pentagon just releasing
the photos and the names of the three
Fallen Soldiers they were stationed at a
base known as Tower 22 on the the border
between Jordan and Syria Fox sources
confirming that the lethal drone had
gotten past the air defenses at the base
because it was mistaken for a US drone
expected to return at the same time so
what did Iran know the Pentagon in the
White House not confirming that story
yet but says Iran had its fingerprints
all over it so far the Iran proxies have
launched over 165 attacks on US forces
it's causing many to point out that the
administration's oneline message against
the radical regime is not working I have
one word
don't don't what is your message to
Hezbollah and its backer Iran
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't what's the message to Iran
don't as President Biden said just don't
exactly one word pretty straightforward
incredible the soft line on Iran
continuing today with the White House
and the Pentagon both ruling out a
direct conflict with Iran we are not
looking for a war with Iran we are not
seeking a conflict with the regime in a
military way we don't seek war we don't
seek further conflict we don't want to
see this widen out into a regional
conflict but we will continue to do
whatever we need to when it comes to
protecting us forces is our focus our
focus is not to escalate this into a
broader Regional War or conflict no one
wants that judine let's just jump right
in get your take
I I I got to tell you we are not looking
for a war with Iran I mean Iran is
sitting there and saying we can do
whatever we want to these people look
Joe Biden is terrified of escalation he
really is he's proven it time and time
again he says we will not tolerate it we
will respond except for the 165 times
that they hit us in Iraq and Syria with
many of our soldiers with traumatic
brain injury which is a lifelong injury
and then two weeks ago Joe Biden's
beating his chest and he says Iran got
the message and that was a couple months
after Sullivan says you know
everything's quiet in the Middle East I
mean we are clueless and feckless on the
world stage we've given Iran a pass
because we don't want to get into what
involved in World War II and I think it
was Mike Pompeo who said this morning we
may not be at war with Iran but they're
at war with us and so we've got to try
to thread this needle in a way where we
recognize they attack us with impunity
we now have soldiers who are dead they
are not stupid what they did with their
drone they followed an American drone
that was turning returning home to uh
Jordan and they literally followed it
and the Americans didn't see it and it
killed three servicemen and injured 34
others we've got American hostages being
held by Hamas we don't even know if
they're dead or alive at this point and
the latest thing is Joe Biden says today
it was wholly uncivilized give me a
break get in there and start fighting
and let me just say one more thing what
did Trump do he killed Soloman what did
Trump do he enforced the sanctions he he
is a he is the person if we look at the
chart of where Iran was financially
under Biden and what they are doing now
under um I mean under Trump and where
they are now with Biden it's very clear
they hurt when we bleed them financially
and what we allow them to do is to sell
oil on the open market give them billion
dollar of money for the hostages and
today Biden had nothing on his schedule
nothing did he call the families what
did he
do there's also Jessica the you know
when you look at that Montage of what
they've been saying that Iran knows not
to do anything well that has proven to
not yeah work and but also when you look
at the administration officials that
spoke out today blinkin Austin
Biden they all had to read the
statements of condolences as if they
don't feel it and I I'm not saying that
they don't but it's strange to me that
the reaction is so subdued and in a way
that where you have to like read every
word that you're sorry that it happened
I think that they were genuinely
surprised which seems strange
considering what has happened over the
last few weeks if you have 150 plus
attacks unfortunately someone is bound
to die from something like this um and I
think that the response does need to be
more heartfelt even if in the most
Craven analysis of this you're thinking
back to the withdrawal from Afghanistan
which was a seminal turning point in
terms of how a lot of Americans felt
about President Biden and the Biden
Administration not necessarily the
decision to leave Afghanistan but how it
was executed in the fact that we lost 13
service members um and people didn't
feel that there was an adequate level of
sorrow and appreciation for what they
had sacrificed for us and that maybe
there was more that we could have done
to ensure that we
got out and that those people survived
so I think that that's something that
needs to be done better I would say it's
secretary Austin's first day back at
work he is recovering um from a Cancer
and reading the statement and but you
would want more in terms of the Biden
Administration financing them the $6
billion has not transferred hands it's
being held by the US and canari
governments you say that with Donald
Trump no one died after he took out
solomani a few months later in March of
2020 there was a rocket missile that had
an Iraqi base and we lost two service
members and I I don't know if you were
critical of him then but there was a
direct response to him taking out a
terrorist that no one disputes and there
was bipartisan congratulations for
Donald Trump in terms of taking that
action so I just want to be fair about
that and accurate about the money and
the financing and what about selling oil
on the open market you said $6 billion
and I that was one of the things won
well let me get Jesse in so this attack
was scheduled to be right at Dawn pre-
Dawn so out a sleeping Barracks to make
sure that there was maximum harm yeah
whatever anti-drone defenses we have
aren't good enough when you saw the map
there's a lot of us service members on
these bases throughout the region and if
we're just going to sit back and receive
pot shots that's not a strategy MH you
can't go out and say don't and the
Iranians do you can't tell Putin don't
and he invades Ukraine you can't tell
the migrants don't come and they come
the guy has no deterrence he's not
respected as a commanderin-chief
and people all across the world are just
running through his red lines now
Kirby's out there saying we don't want
to start a war with Iran we don't want
war in the Mast neither do I no one
wants direct conflict of course not but
why are you acting like oh we don't want
any
trouble
you sometimes you have to use force in
order to deescalate and so far Joe
Biden's done nothing now the strategist
I talked to said you could hit
proxies maybe wouldn't do much you could
even hit the Iranians inside Iran okay
he said the main pressure point is car
Island which is their crude oil terminal
right off their Coast completely wreck
their economy it would take about a
million barrels of oil offline per day
and there's even a bridge to the stupid
island so like it would take years for
them to repair it and then they would
have no money to finance all of these
little proxies now we have to do
something more because right now this is
now the deadliest attack since abig gate
and we're not even including the two
seals we lost that were raiding that
Iranian vessel they say they drowned I
don't even know if that's a true story
because I don't even trust the defense
secretary because he lied about being
under anesthesia for a week so this is a
very critical time I just hope he does
the right thing but I do not trust Joe
Biden to handle this delicately and at
any time right now we could be a week
away from Iran having a nuclear weapon
and at any time as well this could turn
into a national security election yeah
you know I'm just glad that Lloyd Austin
is back I just wish Joe Biden was I mean
when you saw him there he acted like he
was reading the early bird special at
Denny's uh that wasn't a show of
strength even His Life Alert was
blinking it was bad I remember how Trump
was deemed an agent of chaos four years
of turmoil to be replaced by the calm
Cool Waters of Joe Biden what a pyramid
of feces we were sold by the media we're
now experiencing basically a Non-Stop
tornado of incompetence and confusion
from cabul to supply chains to the
Middle East to Ukraine how much more can
we take I mean I agree Trump's words you
know they made people uncomfortable they
made them nuts but the world was kind of
peaceful and maybe there's something to
be said for that that there is peace
through
unpredictability and saying we don't
seek war as Jesse says that's an obvious
statement but you don't have to say that
you don't have to say that I don't know
what Trump would say but he would he
would not say we don't seek war he'd say
let's see what happens you
uh we don't want to get into war but you
know we're happy to oblige if they wish
the way he dealt with uh North Korea I
think what happens is we get stuck in
the prison of two ideas bomb them or do
nothing when in fact you step back you
get out of the prison and you eliminate
the predictable voices the people that
say bomb immediately right and the
people that say no don't bomb there's so
much there and it's like either going
after the proxies right or taking
somehow psychologically taking North
Korea off the list of existential risks
that no one ever considered right there
is a path forward you need to assess who
the players are the timing of these
events how this happened what are you
going to do up until November when the
issue could solve itself with a new
president see these are smaller these
are bigger ideas right which lead to
smaller manageable problems right now
the small prison ideas of bombing or not
bombing will lead to what you're talking
about can I just add to that uh the the
fundamental problem of what's going on
right here is that Joe Biden is so
locked up with Israel right now that's
really what aggravates Iran and all of
this and Russia I think that's the
fundamental problem that IR is
completely anti-semitic and wants to
wipe Israel off the face of the Earth
well of and behind October 7th no I'm
saying the problem for if Joe Biden was
not such a staunch Ally of Israel right
now I doubt that this would be happening
we wouldn't be over there what then why
the the other thing is I would say this
that the house last year passed a bill
it's called the no funds for Iran
Iranian terrorism act it's sitting in
the Senate if you guys want to show that
you can do something at least do that
and show that you have something up your
sleeve in Washington Ione I'm Brian
killme I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube YouTube so subscribe
right now